warum also freunde bei dieser folge das
malheur passiert und zwar eigentlich
nicht mehr sondern openbroadcast da
irgendwie hat das in der schweiz quali
aufgenommen ich hoffe euch gefällt das
video trotzdem hallo freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge aggro zusammen
mit minuten eine und zwar befinden wir
uns in einer partie
das heißt wir spielen zusammen auf einem
server und ich werde hier schon direkt
verfolgt gerade und links unten links
okay die standorte aber aufpassen obama
ist auch der spanien schon wieder die
kleine urlauber meinen da kommt nein da
kommen
ich bin immer noch unten links max will
mich das essen das auch unten links oder
lernen oder sind dort ich dachte rechts
war scheiße an diese obama ich kein
bisschen nach meiner so was ist mir dass
ich super aber ich sehe putin war man ja
ich bin damit gar nicht
manchmal hat sich geteilt okay jetzt
fressen immer auf den straßen drauf
gehen auf mike scheiße aber danach
verdammte kacke ok kommen nach kommen
auf jeden fall auf die linke seite ich
geht langsam nach oben weil unten links
alles okay und ich höre ja als
schutzschild zu fungieren
ok ok vorher war direkt vor ich bin so
wie der marke ok ok wo gehen wir dass
der mars die maßgabe vielleicht fressen
und thematik sehr gut aus
nein nein nein ich bin richtig amanos
nun und x-men verfolgen mich okay im
publikum ist immer noch da oben links
ich bin jetzt unten scheiße aber du hast
du gerade auf scheiße reagiert hier ich
bin jetzt auf der rechten seite all das
ist doch nicht war der server ist doch
voll wiener derby rosemann ist er mein
gott days das was ist das da von
finanzminister da in der flotte und
einer kommt ein riesiger gelber horn
nein bitte nicht bitten da müssen ja ok
schnell weg weg weg weg da ist gelber
pallecchi zerbrochen
immerhin wird von zwei seiten
weil ich zum geilen erst habe die
verfolgen mich alle so dass ein sieg in
coesfeld hat alles verloren
den kann man recht gut essen aber taub
king ist hinter mir nein wenn er dies
bitte bin ich voll am raschen branche wo
bist du so bist du patrick ich brauche
ich bin auf der rechten seite da bist du
hier
[Musik]
ich opfere mein ganzes leben an
ich werde von luca verfolgt dass der
test sein böser zwilling person team
zwischen uns ist kommt bestimmt nie
davor die erde gegessen
darüber werde ich mir etwas gefressen
das ist nichts neues
so kommt jetzt wird jetzt die rasierte
ok jetzt ist sie aber scheiße es klappt
nicht haben wir gehen auf luca darauf
dass das einzige ziel
patrick bist du ihn kann ich nicht wir
sind eins patrick und ich es jetzt den
hier oben den cayman
aber jetzt läuft sie aber jetzt sage
jetzt kann jetzt jemand werden und ins
kreuz kommen hier
ich kann sich holen auto und jetzt hier
das team pro ich verbinde ich aber
gerade wieder so ein bisschen links auch
obama lassen richtig liege damit so ein
bisschen aufpassen dass da oben so ok
warte ich noch ein bisschen abstand zu
dir dass ich dich ein bisschen fressen
trifft ein bisschen hab da kann ich mit
dem schlappen gegen bisschen weg sonst
richtig auf mit jetzt ich habe ja wohl
klar okay ich würde dich okay ich glaube
jetzt gekommen ist ein großer da stand
man nicht man eigentlich spaß als die
musik du kannst jetzt die maus zwischen
deine beiden kreise tun wo er
angeschrieben und verbinden die sich
nadal oder und ist riesig da muss
aufpassen
von dem hotel wird von obama gegessen
gott oh gott oh gott da müssen wir
schnell weg wenn obama den hat dann wird
er locker ein ausländer was auf damit
komme ich schnell ich war sogar schon
keine große hoffnung dass da ist ganz
viel frei nein da ist die 8 steht er
aber du bist jetzt riesig du bist risiko
- zu kleiden ja ich habe alles
rausgeballert für das größere ziel für
das glauben und wie sie ihren großen
traum schweden zu fressen aber diese
gleich groß glaube ich ja aber wie unser
großes ziel ist weltherrschaft werden
heute klappt das weiß ich bin leider zu
klein ich kann die ausmaßen online die
wir haben gerade gutes team etwas recom
mit ja ich komme ich komm du dich noch
zu füttern
[Musik]
ich kann ja auch etwas abgeben ich bin
ich schon bisschen was mitnehmen
ich bin pünktlich wird werden gerade
trägt ja die diese konzentration ich
fahre jetzt nach unten links an sonst
nicht ich werde zu treffen
das hier bloß weg bis unsere einzige
hoffnung hier sind welche die machen
wollen team zusammen und wollen mich so
ein bisschen vermachen glaube ich kann
ihn nicht will dann ich muss
wir nehmen
ich weiß was man dann herum